and then the boss Christoph Post came
later a very well-known
TV producer came to me always there where
is Sissi where is Sissi I'm here
today is Markus I sabia
rolled my eyes inside and said
[ __ ] don't do something like that yes today is
Freddie  Mercury died we have to
do an hour special can you do
it and of course I thought no
and said yes and I stopped
and then that was my first day on
television, so to speak, the big conversation
about the German TV and moving image
landscape with one of them really
knows who
produced and developed the biggest German TV formats
from Welt Millionär to Joko and Klaas
even discovered Stefan Raab let's
talk to Markus wanted Markus
hello I'm very happy Philipp
Markus so you I didn't even
say TV producer legend
I don't think that's completely wrong, always
look at how long you have to at least make
[music]
yes, I made music and
then I realized that I was
n't
going to be the greatest singer in Germany, but
even then I was always in marketing
Yes, I had the idea at the time to
stage Lotto King Karl,
so to speak, and then I got a
concert agent
to become Lotto King Karl a
Hamburg legend or I then
wrote songs for some not
for any great
soap stars, e.g. yes I have with  uhm I
have Dieter Thomas Kuhn the
singing Föhnwelle I produced an album I
did things like that and
then I founded the music publishing house so the
Lotto King Hamburg was somehow very well
known because even at HSV at every
game in front of a 50,000 stadium you helped
invent it, so to speak  or we had
a song back then I had
founded a music publishing house Seegang Musik I
’m from Hamburg so it was through and then
we got a song on the table
that said I had the jackpot
yes and then we said he should
sing it yes and then we did  we were
looking for people who has a really
big mouth has a really big
self-confidence is a great guy and can
sing and that's when Gary Hesemann
came to mind and I
called him my age is awesome and
then we then we then
we have that  thing he
then of course turned out to be a
great artist afterwards but those
were the first that was the beginning of
Lotto King Karl and so I
somehow noticed that I was doing something like
marketing alleged artist Andreas
Elsholz a ZOB actor
seen an autograph session or were
somehow 10,000 teenagers reaching out and
my music was playing like that, well, it was like that and
then I said come on, we have to
make a record with him, yes, he couldn't sing,
but he could speak, well, then we have one
I recorded a little song like that, yes, and that
went into the charts, and so
I noticed that I
enjoyed it, but I also had a
bit of talent, maybe, and then uh
Scout, so yes,
where is what where is what where where is
to tell a story where are good
songs how to
take care which producers
bring together I also wrote my own songs
and that was that was the
first step actually I did but
I also studied and I
still need a bit of money
because that was going slowly  with
GEMA income then I still did the honorable
job of the night watchman
here right next door with you
but Unilever yes and then yes and then at
some point a colleague
or a friend said you have to
do something decent on the side as a job go to
They're always looking for people on TV, yes, and then
I got a job where I ran
along for two weeks. It was a
2-minute show called Pop
News, yes, and then my first day was when
I was supposed to be the normal
editor on my own  I think her name was Sissi
and then I was there Markus,
two minutes first big day and then
I came to the office in the morning and then
Hamburg here in the studio in Hamburg and then
the boss Christoph Post,
later a very well-known television producer,
always came to me  where is Sissi where
is Sissi and I'm telling you no I
'm here today is Markus I saw we
rolled our eyes inwardly and said
[ __ ] don't something like that happen today
Freddie Mercury died we have to
do an hour special can you do
it and  Of course I thought no
and said yes and I stopped
and then that was my first day on
television, so to speak, and then
this Christoph Post somehow
called again and said do you want to? That’s
how the music station was founded and that
was the hottest thing at the time  [ __ ], we
wanted to be the MTV, yes, and then he
asked me if I wanted to do the casting because of
my music publishing company and because of a
few other things,
I
did that and then I had the
first Viva Casting generation I had back then
then brought Heike Makatsch to the start
but also an opti Matthias optenhövel
was there or of course Stefan Raab and
partner
so also found then yes exactly
that was my first real job back then
that was exactly as advertised with
some yes that was that was
just a huge appeal Viva
start a specific station and we looked for a kind of
station family and then it was
my job to get the first people to
Carsten yes and I've
never done that before I had to
google what casting actually is but
then I just did it and  then
that is also quite successful
due to successes in other
areas adjusted
exactly
done but at the same time my music publishing
continued to expand and then of course at
Viva she can have the first chance,
so to speak, then her abstow like
version that I then
produced more or less without  actually
knowing what is producing what but then
I really started to have fun realizing
that you can do it quite
well and I also noticed that
honestly it is not that difficult
because at that time television was very,
yes very, I had something like that
somehow there were certain rules and
we all broke them step by
step yes I think whenever you
break the rules in a creative business erm
existing talent mind you then I
think you can achieve a lot a lot
but what happened back then
so convinced of the people as mine if
you read it like that now somehow Rab
or Mackert are all people who
are then partly relevant for decades or to this day what do you have something like that
do you see because we wanted to
start a kind of family at the time and that
is  it's what we did too, I
think that's what
makes broadcast successful anyway, a family with
faces with people where the
viewer says the viewer, man,
I'd like to be part of it like that and that's it
and honestly it was
n't that difficult us  they did
n't want to copy MTV because there were a
few faces we wanted the people who
aren't really that different from
the viewers that
we wanted would Nils bokelberg with
the cap there was
a Heike Magath of course somehow like that
that girly like that was somehow tattooed at the time
and there was also a question of whether
she was a bit serious with the
glasses and so on and
we then founded this family but
honestly also because of the huge
hype that people preferred to make back then yes I
think and  Due to the constant
live presence that the
presenter had, it
became very, very big and yes, and
of course I found great joy
in it and I also
discovered this passion that I
had before when producing music
that I noticed  I
really enjoy imagining things like that
and then seeing that
they somehow initiate
a kind of movement on the screen or elsewhere,
but you are still
highly relevant after Viva, after this pop culture, that was
really back then  I could imagine
but the center there was no
internet yet, so somehow everything
revolved around how we were
made, trends were made, people were made, there were
somehow a lot of young people and that's how
you are, but if you
read it like that  Quite surprisingly I
went to Munich to a call-in station
so it felt like the absolute opposite of that. I was
n't
always interested in that. That was what
always interested me. I'm still
incredibly interested and it  it was just
that I
was on the road a lot back then with my products and
my songs and my music themes and
such and yes, at some point
Christiane zu Salm just called me who was with
you Kofler together with a partner
in this new crazy
thing  live, he did
n't have a bad image back then either, it only
came later, yes, through me,
my colleagues, no, it
was such that this station should
just become a call TV station, yes,
you have that if you wanted it  was
honestly back then if you look at
what Instagram is today yes so
interaction interaction with a
direct marketing function that was
actually this basic idea yes and then
I was interested in the madness
he has an insane always difficult back then there
were already three
program directors had already
been fired and  then Christiane said
come on, do you want to do it and then
I said yes straight away I always said
yes or no straight away when I made my decisions when it came to something new I always said yes or
no straight away it's still the same today
yes I can feel if I'm going to do something
I want to know if I can do something if I have something electrified that
electrified me and then we
established this dial-up television in Germany
very very profitable no it was unbelievably
profitable even then there was a
travel shopping channel and that was one of those yes
that was  then a larger
family and I realized at the time for
my career that I
could also lead, I did
n't know that at first, because again
you didn't have to lead, you
just had to produce and be cool, yes,
and, and  and make decisions
but here I noticed that it
's also great to take people on
a trip
we were in really
good times that you wouldn't believe that
but first of all what sales because we
were at you can  say today we
were at had a turnover of
I think 90 million and had an
ewdmagage of 40% and over 40 percent that
was one of the most profitable
televisions I think you ever had that was
why we were bought
by von heimserbahn von von
ProSieben Sat.1 and then Viva
took over that people wrote an SMS, so to speak, or took
part, so they voted
or took part and that
the money can't be paid for through advertising, that
can primarily be done through these SMS messages,
that was only possible  via SMS
operators via these so call so
call services, so to speak,
and that was a big discussion, is it
a lottery or is it a game of chance
and we we just
tried to talk to people that night
we just made real live
television, sometimes from
the same  Studio for seven, eight, nine
other countries did that too, that means
we copied it, we had something similar
to this one, I somehow find it very
impressive to be here in your
company, it's also a
bit like a cult in a
positive sense  this way and that
reminds me a bit of the
sun, how was time, for example, because the
people are somehow is a certain
attitude to life yes and and that and that
had Viva back then but of course it was
new for us live because of
course that kind of thing  a bit the bad guys
of established television were yay
competition that has to be
done because that and so but it was insanely
successful and yes and that was the
basic idea for the competition so
the actual idea was quite
simple we do talk we do talk
people  definitely want to call for money
no one called yes then
we will do an auction there somehow has an
idea we are giving away a ring from
some zebromy there are also
millions no one called then
we started somehow um then
we touched the only thing that
worked was then somehow  that
we noticed we
threw in a lottery and then suddenly I was
in my office I have a viewer where
you could always see how many live calls
were at once like otherwise always like five
ten 50 suddenly someone came
running up Markus Markus you have to get
yours  Coming to the office what's going on is
someone collapsing but what's going on
Markus Markus then I saw this viewer
yes and we suddenly somehow
made 40,000 calls in one hour
40,000 yes so competition I thought
first win yes money yes I first
thought well then  the viewer is probably
broken but it wasn't broken and then
this success story started to be
refined and that was
a lot of fun and we had
really good people with us
on the trip back then Konrad Albert
later um later board member the
positive 1  Gruppe was the lawyer at the time,
thank God, for 9 Live and my
partner was a manager and that's how
we did it, well, and
then at some point it happened why I was
asked by 9 Live
to become the managing director of Ende mol, I know that  until tonight
known production room ne so John
de Mole dutch percentage
taken over what was there like the formats
well that was so that this this company
actually only had three real
formats that were in each country
one mega successful only in Germany
not at that time it  At that time there was only who wants to be a
millionaire, only love counts with Kai
Pflaume and there was Big Brother and the
other trends, the company in
Germany actually had everything so bad at the time,
but of course the demands were
much higher and that
was that  my first real management
well my second real management
position as boss there it was a
mega time how big because the company
was so clean back then the company was about 90 million sales at the time
I think
wait then
well that was quite a few
Formats more but those were the
most important formats and I made
my mark right from the start because
I didn't see myself as a
television producer but
primarily as an entrepreneur said we
have to we have to expand this company
by founding daughter film yes by
we're starting with the so-called boutique
model, I've always called it designer shops,
like now, like chefs
who don't have to be in their restaurant every evening,
we just
have certain brands, and
then we founded Wiedemann and Berge that was the first deal
one of the always  still
and I think that's great because
there are many companies that we
founded are still incredibly
successful yes percentages in Germany
so they make really big films
and which
were recently taken over by Fred Kogel's company
because I then  Yes,
I left Animal at some point and then
they reoriented themselves and are now
lost under the roof, but
back then we founded a mountain again
and had 78 mega-successful years
much much more so
again Berg is still one of
the hippest and most successful
German fiction good yes companies um
then of course we
founded Florida Florida TV
also addressed yes we we have
at some point we have so I think
Joko and Klaas were with  MTV just
got kicked out and of course I thought they
were cool, somehow it was great and
then I met up with Klaas and had
coffee in Berlin and so we
said breakfast, come on, let's do it,
let's
do something of our own and then be  Yes, even then
we did the first
formats back then as a subsidiary of
Ende mol, then it was a John Venture
between Endemol and then of course the
boys, like Joko and Klaas, and then
the management and then that was
the second big thing  Then came the
third company, Jörg Pilawa, that was an
old school buddy of mine in Hamburg, that's
exactly what we founded,
Mr. P, yes, and there are nice
stories with Jörg and so on, yes, and
these these stories then
made it big at the end of the day  so of course we live
then also for other artists
super interesting aha here Florida
again a mountain and and we became have
grown insanely in the time
then we still took over the bill from the
end of mol then the end of moonlight what
should he throw in the garbage you back then  yes
you made it so big with participants no
and exactly and that was the reason
for me personally
to go to the next step at some point
because of course I had noticed
that we the the companies I was
involved in sailing but I have  Of course,
I only participated in live in this huge gold rush, so to speak, only as a
manager and not as an
entrepreneur, and then although my
company had I was already somewhat
independent because at that time I was listening to swell music
somehow as well as to live against
Universal had sold and
then of course animal that then
grew insanely and that was also
an insane traveler insane
time and I also think it's always
important that you, well, that you
also, uh, I think as an entrepreneur,
I also think it's important that you look at each other
so not only where did you get in how
was the exit but also something like that is what
has really grown yes and that's what
I find when I go back to
my Berg Florida TV and many formats
kitchen impossible so even at one
molt time there are so many great  just
great things were created
exactly
yes they have kitchen impossible
i pitched that with one at the time so
the idea was to
try them out and i went with the
head of development from animal to the
head of vox at the workshop
Bernd Reichert and then we were
we had such a meal with us wanted to
demonstrate it's fun
to try it that was
from the canteen from the day before and we
opened it and it smelled unbelievable yes
so there was really a choking reflex
on the other side of the
table but  In the end it was a legendary
pitch and it was also a
legendary show in the end and yes, and many of the
boys already knew that the room
would be part of it, I
don’t think it was clear at the time, so
then we got on board and
then one of our producers
at the time was still a producer with a
voucher if steffensmeier
made this trip with Tim and
made this successful format, but
many other formats have also emerged because around
the world, for example,
yours or do you
only recognize a good idea  that you then help it
that it grows up or are you
already there when it was created
I'm not
there when it was created, I am I I believe
that I
can tell the difference between a good idea and a mediocre one  but
I don't think it's so much about
companies just the idea it's
always about it makes yes who puts
the horsepower on the road and it makes a big
difference whether a Tim Mälzer kitchen
impossible lives and works and
rocks or whether someone does  Yes it does and that's
why I think it
's the crucial entertainment business
that brings the idea together with the
right people and
then and that's my strength then
to fire up the engine and get it on the
road yes and then even when
I feel that  there something uh that there something
happens then I'm also then I'm
also a terrier yes then I'll stick with
it until it rocks I
don't think there's any format
that we used to
think we thought that as a team
Wouldn't it be mega hits that weren't
brought to the streets at some point not
everything became mega hits some
also became mega flops but we always got it
onto the streets and mostly
it still worked on the streets where
it means producing then also
selling a station  because it's already
the core job in which you place an idea
with the broadcaster so that
it still broadcasts the paid absolutely that's that
that the decisive factor
at least at the time was that all of that
decided to find a partner
to find a broadcaster later  then to
find a streamer who then
broadcasts it and who then makes it big,
yes, and he is the
quasi as a partner what kind of magnitude is that
so if you
say never around the world then please
when the 10 episodes or  something like that and
then you say it costs
5 million or how do you have to
introduce it, yes, I don't
know the exact
price anymore, but
of course it depends, from until there are
TV shows, the costs are well over a
million, so the costs  as much as a
one episode yes like a detached house
a good location okay the world sounds
too expensive now because the four
trips for people I can't
say exactly but certainly so say something like
magnitude detached house a very
good location costs a very very good
television show  uhm well in an ok location tell me
you live in Hamburg so
I would say ok uhm and there are
also tv channels that is also very
important the costs are just like
20 30 40,000 that is of course
dates they are more like them  these bread
and butter shops and there is a
good one, let me say a manufactory, there are
specialized people who
are particularly good at one thing and
others who are particularly good at the really big ones
and erm yes that
’s then different things that we err
expensive
Well, those are fiction series, I
think that's fiction series,
of course, are the most expensive things at the end of the day,
but how did things go for you, so
if you stopped at the end of the mole
and the end of the mull shine, there was this
merger but  you really weren't
an entrepreneur, did
you then somehow want to
start your own business one day
exactly then, at some point, I had
in between, of course, I had, I was, I
've invested in a few things here and there,
and of
course, I've always been an
entrepreneur as an entrepreneur  felt and
I also always managed the one mutschein
and always managed it entrepreneurially
and then at some point there came a
phase where I notice that now at the moment
where also the scissors or
others became American or that
is I had that  Feeling that
I had
arrived at the end of my journey and then yes and
then there was the huge opportunity
to set up independent television producers in Germany again with the clear
goal of becoming number one in
To become Germany and also with the goal of saying
we want to found a company where we
take people with us on the
journey entrepreneurially
where we can easily make careers
but where we also go beyond the
TV business  Being
able to work with artists and basically
getting the chance to
build up some real entertainment, a real entertainment powerhouse in Germany and that was
five years ago and I did
n't think long about who
initiated it, so where did this idea come from
yes there was barney panager
his global company now the
the largest TV production company in the world
yes
exactly the largest TV producer they
spoke to each other yes of course
i was already networked with the CEO marco patati
at that time because because marco was
also out  brought me to an end at that time,
yes, that means we had very
good contact and yes, and at some point
it just happened that bodyguay actually
grew in every country in Germany,
but you only had this 50 percent
stake in Brainpool brancool is
also a legendary company and  with a
legendary story, all the great
comedians grew up there,
alongside Stefan bastian Pastewka,
Mario Barth, Luke Mockridge, Anke Engelke
Stromberg, so everything that happened during
that time went through the
Brainpool halls and then you only had
this 50% participation and nothing else
in Germany,
so to speak, and the other
georg-grabersteinmann and us
from time to time to other
shareholders like that and there only had this
50% stake but wanted to
grow in Germany as well,
actually wanted someone to do it
and maybe
a little more  more like that and then there was
the possibility at some point when I
dropped out,
then there were talks and then they
said okay, can you imagine that and
then of course it was clear that I
would also take part as an entrepreneur and  then
we are we together we
started this journey and then we
kind of handed them money
and you started
shopping first yes I did but also yes
we gave money
but I also did of course
Money invested, logically, we
just said, no, we need something here
and of course we then
started to get the brain pool
participation, logically logically, to
get it to 100% at some point,
not bought out, but we we
are partners, we then have a
partnership, a partnership
made of it and Stefan is still
there and we then of course we
also bought other companies
then we must have sold it
exactly so to the suprempool is
now a subsidiary of bandita
Germany 100% subsidiary of Bar Ninja
Germany and then there is  we
founded the Gang Productions with Arno
Schneppenheim, who
was already a legendary producer at the time, who
was also the managing director of Florida the
year before and a companion of mine,
we then started with the panicked
Productions in Cologne, which
is now 5 year-end
Productions  there are now 150
employees and many, many great
projects just came
about then gut Heims was added well then of course at the
end of Mulle my former
employer who we then practically brought back into
the family was of course
also a great thing for you when the
company  So how much money
have you put into your hands over the years to build up what you have today,
so a lot of money was
put into your hands worldwide and
a whole lot of 100
million plus was also made in Germany yes sure but yes um
internationally just sure but  in
Germany the second-mentioned
sum is okay, that means you have
invested a nine-digit sum to
make acquisitions, then you are
really the mla business
and less purely production now,
or are you already  right, so
to speak yes arrived in M&A yes we
are meanwhile we are the bunny
of the group in Germany there are 25
companies and not just TV
production companies like the ones just mentioned
also production as the as the the
state the good times then and and
of course
brain pool than as the comedy company
but and endemutschein, so to speak,
but we then also
invested in artist agencies Sascha
Rinne Management with Giovanni
Zarella, for example, is an artist from Sascha
Rinne Management who we
work very closely with by
believing many others
Artists are there but also the
MTS MTS is a tour organizer where
he makes Schröder e.g. tournament and
many other great
artists how many people means
overall for the bunnychia construct in
Germany so overall we are
now a bit over believe  I have 1,600
employees in the
various companies and the location
is in Germany,
at least let's say more than 300 and you
yourself have just said that it is now involved,
so that means it
somehow belongs to 10 20%
or less then  so but two share
all the time yes okay okay
at least 10% of a company that
somehow 1300
so already entrepreneurial now
a bigger wheel yes it is a
wonderful company the most important thing is
that we have
a lot of
independent different companies in Germany
that our  The concept is not
that we build up a company like a group
and that the group doesn't
reg- ister a company, it's
about us different
artists artists producers
personality on the journey that you do
n't get top producers no
top producers  if you say here here
is the the the contract link and
it's also about the producers
percent want to be seen yes
he wants that to be her baby that should
be her thing and I think we can do that
quite, really well that we  Yes,
that we also create careers
in our group, that they are visible,
yes, and that is why Bunny Jay as a
group, because that is always a kind of Star
Alliance, yes, it's similar to one
if you take the Lufthansa stables, there
's just that  the Euro Wings
but there is also an Asian airline
Austrian there are an incredible number of
airlines that also differ
yes where it is where is a completely different flight
experience is also a different management,
so to speak, to the entrepreneurs who are now
founding these individual companies, I mean
that sounds a bit  just like in the past
with the creative agencies, there was then
a big agency and then there were
different GmbHs under one roof,
but even then I sometimes
asked myself why could a super creative
producer not do it alone,
why does it need why does it have to be under yours
That's a good question,
but I can tell you that very, very clearly,
namely if I if if
we somehow we two Philipp and
Markus aren't Productions mine are
such a brother that's awesome we're
both kinda good guys
determined for what are we going to do then our
one and two productions are all great but
what is of course very important if you
are a producer you
first need financial resources yes that
means you have to get very good
people first of all you need to make the advance payments
for that you need first of all  Money that is
very very important and the second topic
is you need formats we have
of course international the banditers
a huge the largest format catalog in
the world then there is
information like Massinger yes or Big
Brother yes or or and lots of
really big Temptation Island  and much much
more that's the second topic what
you need what formats the
third topic that you what you
need you also need at the end of the day
you want to focus on the creative as a producer
yes you
want to tell stories you
want films  shoot and would like to
deal with artists what
very few producers want is to
do the controlling job, so to speak yes they
do the legal job lawyers are
expensive lawyers are also there are
good bad lawyers so
we take all these things off the producers' hands and
say focus on yourself completely  on your
on your product yes on your creation
be a manufactory that means you
can make your company with your name you
are in the light you it's your it
's your your baby and we're
going on this journey together, so to speak, and you
have our trust and  you have a
certain degree of independence to
do that and that is a very attractive
offer and is it a problem for you or for
you that your customers
end up doing this often on TV channels
that they are all
going through hard times now that the
viewer numbers  are declining and you
can take a look at it a bit.
Share price, for example, isn’t that
so pleasing RTL, you can also
read that there are now a wide variety of
challenges lurking again,
you realize that it’s still a
future business if you can continue to grow
because in the end you can only  grow
if the customers also somehow if they go
well if they if they grow so
our customers yes I understand from
the customer relationship always as well as an
address partnership yes that means
ours are our partners just like
the streamers are Amazon or
Netflix
but they  diversify, too, that
means the broadcaster pro 71
now also has a platform with joint
has many other business models,
just like RTL, of course, with RTL plus,
just like the public
broadcasters have their media libraries, that means
for me as a producer or for us
as  The production company is above all
decisive what the
people out there want to consume more and more
content yes and there are
different ways of
consuming content in the past, for example when I
go to Stuttgart Business yes
there used to be some records
yes then there were  any interviews
on the radio and in between it has always
become huge business because
people like to hear it if there is
another medium now on which your
podcasts work better then
you would also see, so to speak, that
you might be thinking about the platform
and do the same  You
TV stations too I think that there is
no content crisis in
Germany at all there is
no crisis among consumers
consumers want to continue to spend a lot of money
to see the best, very best
content, that means as long as we make an
effort to tell the best stories, that’s
how long it will be  always be
possible to
build up a customer business in the end and we, uh,
as bundyjay uh, of course, also notice
that the station that our partners
go through with us, yes, that's
certainly right, that's much more
in the direction of streaming, that's
certainly right too  But we are
also diversified in terms of our content
because we do
n't just see ourselves as TV producers.
For example, in times when there
may be fewer classic TV orders,
the
live business will perhaps be a little
more our own platform  I think
it's also important to say
that there's also the bunninger live
artist brands I think one of
the biggest with myspass one of the biggest
one of the biggest platforms for online
content is yes we make 14,000
clips every year which are individually
configured  are with great
material from TV totally about whatever
Stromberg and everything possible and that
means we make sure that our
content is king the most important thing is to
make great content to make the best
content about different
manufacturers about different
independent production companies to
create content  it can be live, it
can be online content, it can
be any form of audio-visual content, yes, and at the same time we always try
to find the best possible partner
and um, that's always possible if you produce the best
content,
okay,
now tell me  before you with
all the companies and formats there's
probably a portfolio
analysis like that, but like the
management consultancy I've
seen earlier there's only the
cashcaust and the upcoming stars and
the living badgers and stuff like that are
currently the most important  Formats
that you have in the portfolio are gone
so it's definitely um if I'm in the
TV area at the beginning TV Total is
of course a and the new one that's
an incredibly important format NEW How
old yes that's um TV Total is an
incredibly important format and
incredibly successful
alive ran again yesterday evening
um well TV Total is a very
successful are Martina is a very
successful formats of schein it is
also formats like my L who
is your local in dailies that are very successful with us
maybe I will come to  yes I
the list is getting longer that's why the
shell of the lions is also a very
successful format thanks to our new
advertising new pictures it was for the
Sony that we acquired in
Germany that's really a
very successful format too I must
n't forget it  Celebrity Big Brother is
a very successful format Schlag den
Star is a very successful format
Temptation Island is a very
successful format somehow still a
bit involved do you look at them
at all or do you know you will be
asked about the motto no idea
want to make a new deal with  a
transmitter take a look at it or when when when when
the lights ask those
responsible um well me I do
n't look at everything of course because we
have a total of four we're doing um I do
n't know how many but somehow I think
we have over
I think almost 400 fires on my lap on TV
a year, that means
we basically have at least
one Brandon show on air every evening and if I
saw all of them I wouldn't
do anything else, yes, and what I'm
always interested in is  what is the
pipeline of a company yes that means
which producer producers are working
on what actually interests me
the future always more than
than the present
is decisive for me what what is
currently in the making for example
fiction area yes I have now completely
forget the made for a subsidiary
of ours in Berlin has just
relaunched new thrillers for RTL an den Dünen super
successful we do the Dresden
Tatort e.g. I also think it’s a really, really
great format exactly and so and so of course
we can of course it’s
not  my job is to deal intensively with
these materials in advance,
but my job is
always to see
where our companies are at
how what is the creative
power where where where can we maybe
do a bit more how can we
maybe do it too  in our portfolio in
the so if you understand it as an ecosystem as far as
the artist agencies are concerned,
we are how do the
artist agencies work together with our
production companies are the formats
divided correctly within the group
we are well divided with the genres
from say daytime to primetime  to
fiction to non-fiction and of
course what do we do just a
business model we have invested in
the influence vision for example
a company that deals with yes in
particular with with marketing
on platforms like insta e.g.
a great company from Austria
we  of course we can take care of
the around the Biele have now
founded another brandstudio so
Bunny deja brandstudio where we also work
directly with Branson and case e.g.
Froster we have we do the Wok World Cup
yes they are a great format by the way
exactly the Rock at  er Pro7 has
just been launched again
last year in November we
did that and of course we marketed it and
partnership with the broadcaster we of
course marketed it yes and
Frosta as a partner of our bunnyjay
brand studio so to speak
invested there and we  have sat with the
with the workbook knossi among other things
and and other creators
we have achieved more than 40 million more than 40 million
views yes, which
is an amazing thing and that
just shows that it's not just we're
not just talking about  classic television and
we're talking about branding, we're talking about
simply evaluating entertainment events in entertainment series, yes, and
I think ours differs from
other maybe classic
TV production companies that we
mean it seriously and that we
deal with it a lot
Actually, Stefan Raab
is also involved in individual productions and then stands behind the camera
and that will be or something
is really
at the Rock World Cup then you don't see them
anymore but walks around there and makes
sure that it looks good first
Stefan is simply a legend than
as an entertainer one of the biggest
Germans also very successful as a producer
okay that means he is  also
now in the end your business partner until
today yes our time that is
interesting because bunnyjay
Germany that is the vehicle in which you
are all involved because the 10%
more or less one still um but
the remaining shares then belong to
Bunny Jay globally, so to speak  and that
in turn largely belongs to the
richest person in the world in this
Frenchman who is from the Lord or no, that
's a long way off but I think
that there's again under shares with
various other companies
but then who is the founder of the banji group
worldwide  the Funki but a
French who I would have read that
the that the gentleman just the of the
ass because the colleague is also plays a role
it may be that he is
part of the social circle
but is the Frank oBI is the
main shareholder and  also the
founder of the bunnyjay Group yes and yes and
that's also why it
's also possible in countries like
Germany and me too and many
other countries to do what we
do here because because because that's the
philosophy of this group  is just we
are producers from the heart
everyone who works there has exactly this
entrepreneurial producer history
and bunnyjay was founded
by Stefan who used to
be multchef in France at the end and then
built up this company
through various takeovers as a
worldwide  Venture has set up and
the philosophy is that you
somehow try to win over entrepreneurial producers in every country,
yes, and who then in turn win over other
producers and entrepreneurial
producers and and
this business but never as a
classic mma business
but always as  um always with the
passion of producing with the
passion that is storytelling